[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Tannenbaum ESPN NFL front office
Insider and former general manager with
the Jets he founded the 33rd team a
football Think Tank consisting of former
NFL head coaches GMS grad students
creating in-depth analysis on college
and pro football and he's provided us
with that with his his thoughts on the
Chicago Bears who are on the clock right
now Mike explained to the audience why
what you would do with that number one
overall pick
Dan great to be with you I would draft
Bryce Youngs who I think is going to be
a superstar in this league I think he
has great arm strength great accuracy
great anticipation this is not a bash of
Justin Fields I like him I think Justin
Fields is a good quarterback that has a
chance to be a very good quarterback but
if we could get let's say a first and a
third round pick for Justin fields and
reset the clock on a rookie quarterback
contract we would have a massive amount
of resources if we look at Jacksonville
Dan and they go sign Christian Kirk
Brandon Sheriff Evan Ingram amongst
others we could go get three to four
players with the cap room and get
another two really good players with
what we could get in terms of draft
Capital by trading Justin Fields how do
you know Bryce young is going to be
great
he has every industry that he will be he
has all the tangibles and when you go
back to last weekend I thought something
really remarkable happened they were
playing Kansas State in a game that
meant nothing no Championship available
and he plays the whole game so does Will
Anderson another top five pick but when
somebody has the tangibles of his
ability to throw the football and his
intangibles I'll sign up for that now
the one critique about him is going to
be his size
um some people like Todd mcshade my
colleague at ESPN you know kind of
compare him a little bit to Steph Curry
I think he has lower body flexibility
and enough movement skills where well
size will be an issue I think he'll be
able to overcome it who should trade for
Justin fields
like who shouldn't is a better question
I'll give you a dozen teams from Indy
New York Jets Saints Tampa Bay you can
make an argument for Houston Seattle uh
there would be a really robust market
for Justin Fields who still has a number
of years left on his rookie deal he just
wouldn't have five and I think Fields is
someone that has to get better in terms
of his accuracy he had four games this
year where his completion percentage was
below 50 percent but he's High character
he's been productive and I think he'll
continue to get better
yeah I'm trying to figure this out
though if the Bears don't want him but
then you're saying all these other teams
are going to want Justin fields and the
way I would couch it Dan if you and I
were running the Bears and we were
talking to other teams I would just say
hey look we're happy with Justin fields
we had an unexpected opportunity no one
thought the Texans would win on you know
the last game of the season and because
of it
um we just feel like Bryce Young's a
little bit of an upgrade but if you
juxtaposed Justin Fields with ironically
one of his former Ohio State teammates
CJ Stroud or will lettuce from Tennessee
there'll be a number of teams Dan that
will see
Justin Fields as a better Prospect than
Stroud or Levis and therefore again be
it the Colts or one of these other
quarterback 80 teams as you know what I
there's good tape on Justin fields from
the last two years I don't have to worry
about this Penn State transfer and will
lettuce okay but so what you're saying
is instead of taking CJ Stroud or will
Levis if you're the Colts or the Texans
you would gladly take Justin Fields
right because you know what you have
like you've seen two years of tape The
Good the areas you have to get better
and again let's take Jalen hurts a year
ago we would say hey we've seen some
good of Jalen hurts but he has to get
better with downfield accuracy Jalen
hurts was in the nvp candidacy again
because he did that he got better in the
areas he did and if you look at Justin
Fields with a similar narrative a good
Young quarterback that had areas to get
better you can make a very similar
argument
what do you do if you're the Colts
I scour I I scour for a quarterback I'm
not getting off the phone with the Bears
if they want to keep fields and I can
get Bryce young I'm not getting off the
phone because you can't overpay for
greatness and you can't overpay for a
quarterback and you look at from the day
luck walked out of the door you know
from Philip Rivers to Carson Wentz to
Matt Ryan it just has a work so there's
no price to pay for greatness at the
quarterback position if you were the GM
of the Packers and you sit down with
Aaron Rodgers what do you want to hear
from Aaron Rodgers
a two-year commitment an unconditional
two-year commitment because one thing
that we can't debate is the chemistry
with some of those young receivers
Christian Watson their second round pick
Romeo Dobbs their fourth round pick Dan
it got better as the year went on he
wasn't there for the off season program
he needs to have a unconditional
two-year marriage to say I am all in I'm
not paying you 60 million dollars to
show up 17 times Aaron I'm paying you 60
million dollars next year to be the CEO
of this team starting in February and
you know what's interesting Dan when you
really look at that game their defense
held up okay their run game held up
Aaron Rodgers if we're just being
candidan Aaron Rodgers is who sent them
home
yeah he's been average uh quite a few
times I mentioned the stat of all the
quarterbacks who played every game he's
the only one who didn't throw for at
least 300 yards in a game now I don't
want to rely on him to throw for 300
yards because I do like the running game
and the defense
but Aaron was subpar and another loss at
home in a must-win situation
yeah and look he's still by far gives
him the best chance to win although I do
like Jordan love I think he's gotten
better but clearly Aaron Rodgers gives
them the best chance but I can't have
him half in and half out like this team
is too young and too formative in terms
of those receivers like he needs to
spend as much time with them as possible
and if he does give him the way the
defense played down the stretch they
could be right back to where they were
you know in terms of you know the NFC
North but it starts with him yeah but
how do you broach the topic of we're
moving on from you without saying we're
moving on from you yeah it's blunt force
trauma California that was the old Rex
Ryan one force trauma we're gonna sit
down we're gonna thank you for
everything you're an all-time great we
we want you back from the worst way but
Aaron I want to hear that you're going
away for two months to find yourself in
South America and give us an answer in
the middle of March that doesn't help us
like we need to know this is a
partnership this is a marriage if you're
in great if you're not we're
disappointed but understand but we can't
let this go on for several months while
you travel the world it's just not where
the organization and by the way Dan you
have a stronger hand this year than last
year because at least you've seen some
inklings of progress with love
Jimmy Garoppolo Derek Carr they're the
same price who do you want
if you can guarantee the health of
Garoppolo I'm going with Jimmy G my
concern about Carr you made an
interesting point about if we're trading
Justin Fields the question is going to
be well why you know Josh McDaniels is a
really good quarterback coach and if he
can't get to work with Derek Carr I'm
going to have pause for concern and put
Garoppolo over him
great to talk to you as always thank you
uh for your insights bud
thanks Dan appreciate you having me it's
Mike Tannenbaum ESPN NFL front office
Insider former Jets general manager also
worked for the Dolphins and he founded
the 33rd team it's a think tank in-depth
analysis on college and pro football